le saint germain cette brasserie bien
connu du milieu politique tourangeau
était l'endroit idéal pour rencontrer
les auteurs d'un livre qui veut
réhabiliter la mémoire de l'ancien maire
de tous nos enquêtes sur un suicide
politique et le travail commun du
journaliste arnaud roy et d' alain dayan
ex collaborateur et ami de jean germain
j'ai eu beaucoup de peine j'en ai encore
je vais pas le cacher et en même temps
le l'émotion que je peux avoir n'enlève
rien à la crédibilité de ce que je dis
ou à la véracité de ce que je peux dire
absolument rien et tout ce que je dis
dans ce livre est vrai les faits
reviennent sur le travail considérable
que jean germain a accompli pour la
ville durant les presque vingt ans où il
a dirigé et sur la façon dont se sont
déroulés ces derniers jours
ces faits là ne sont pas contestables
mais dans cet ouvrage on trouve aussi
des analyses des suppositions et des
approximations tout en reprochant à
quelques rares articles de presse
d'avoir évoqué une liaison supposée
entre jean germain et sa collaboratrice
lysanne les auteurs tombe dans les
travers qu'il dénonce en affirmant par
le biais d'un témoignage anonyme que
cette liaison aurait bien existé
plus gênant encore il suppose qu'à
l'origine de la faire se trouvera un
mystérieux corbeau qui voulait nuire à
jean germain et qui aurait organisé un
complot
cette personne humainement parlant
j'aimerais comprendre sa motivation
voilà c'est un truc vous pouvez
comprendre moi je suis allé je devais
aller chercher jean germain ce matin là
jamais pu le trouver pour cause cette
personne là sans l'accusé évidemment
parce que c'est un ensemble de faits ne
sait pas lui le responsable
il fait partie d'une chaîne dans le
bouquin on appelle ça l'effet papillon
j'aimerais qu'il ait le courage de venir
soit par les arnaud roy soit me parler
pour s'expliquer et que nous fasse
comprendre ses motivations pour la
sortie de ce livre à quinze jours du
procès des mariages chinois nous donne
l'occasion de redire qu à l'origine de
cette affaire il n'y a ni corbeau ni
complot en 2011 ce sont de simples
citoyens tourangeaux qui contacte le
canard enchaîné puis france 3 à visage
découvert pour nous apprendre que des
opérations financières
étrange se déroule dans le cadre de ces
mariages ce type d' informateur est ce
qu'on appelle dans le métier
une source ce sont eux qui déclenche une
enquête dans laquelle l'essentiel est de
savoir si de l'argent public a été
détournée ou pas